كيف يتحقق
[موسيقى]
السلام اولا دعنا نبدا من حيث ان اسرائيل
دوله
الاحتلال لوثت المعنى الحقيقي لهذه الكلمه
الساميه من خلال الممارسات على مدار 75
عام واصبحت هذه كلمه في ذهن الملايين من
الشعب الفلسطيني وشعوب المنطقه والعالم
كلمه حقيقه مربوطه باستمرار اضطهاد ونكران
اسرائيل لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني لماذا لان
اسرائيل خلطت في كل هذه السنوات من
محاولات التوصل الى سلام حقيقي وعادل
وشامل خلطت بين السلام
والامن
وايضا
تقصدت ان يكون الامن لطرف واحد اي فقط
لدوله الاحتلال وبالنسبه لهم الامن يعني
هدوء واستقرار في حاله استمرار الاحتلال
غير القانوني الاستعمار غير القانوني
الحصار غير الاخلاقي وغير القانوني نظام
الفصل العنصري اذا بالنسبه لهم السلام هو
تحقيق الامن لاسرائيل فقط مع استمرار
اضطهاد الشعب الفلسطيني ونكران حقوق وهذا
بالممارسه الفعليه على مدار عقود من الزمن
اذا السلام يعني لاسرائيل
الخضوع والخنوع
والاستسلام للامر الواقع هذا هو
وبالتالي السؤال التالي كيف كيف وصلنا
لهذه الحاله بالرغم من العديد من
المحاولات
لان دوله الاحتلال لديها عقليه استثنائيه
غير مسبوقه في التاريخ البشري الاولى انهم
يؤمنوا بالحلول العسكريه يؤمنوا بان الحل
امني يؤمنوا بان الطريق الوحيد لابقاء هذه
الحاله غير القانونيه من
الاضطهاد هي من خلال ممارسه عنف غير مسبوق
ضد الشعب المحتل وهذا تشاهدونه اليوم على
شاشات التلفاز في غزه وفي القدس وفي الضفه
وفي كل اماكن تواجدنا هم يؤمنوا بالعقيده
العسكريه وان الحل الوحيد دائما مع الشعب
الف فلسطيني هو حل عسكري ليس قانوني ليس
سياسي ليس انساني ثانيا هم يؤمنون دوله
الاحتلال يؤمنون انهم الضحيه هم الضحيه
ليس الشعب الذي تحت الاحتلال الذي يمارس
عليه الاستعمار تسرق ارضه وتهدم بيوته
ويتم قتل اطفاله ونساؤه وابنائه ويتم اسر
اطفاله ويتم اسر شبابه
وكباره لا الاحتلال هو الضحيه لانه
العقليه في عقليه الضحيه انهم مجبرون
تخيلوا ان دوله الاحتلال مجبره على اضطهاد
مجبره على احتلالا مجبره على سرقه ارضنا
وعلى سرقه منازلنا وعلى هدم منازلنا مجبره
على فرض نظام فصل عنصري ضدنا هم مجبرين هم
غلابه يعني هم في عقليتهم في ذهنهم
يعتقدون انه الشعب الفلسطيني يجبرنا
يضطرنا لفعل هذا غير مسبوق ثالثا
هناك ايمان بتفوق عرقي داخل دوله الاحتلال
وانظروا الى الحكومه الحاليه الى سموتريتش
وبينغ فييه وقبلهم نتنياهو تفوق عرقي
حقيقي سوبريماسي هذا التفوق العرقي يجعلهم
يفكرون ويمارسون اي شيء بدون حساب وبدون
عقاب هم مقتنعين انهم يستطيعون فعل اي شيء
كما يفعلون الان في اطفالنا في نسائنا في
مدارسنا في مستشفياتنا في بنانا التحتيه
في غزه والضفه الغربيه في جنين ونابلس وكل
مكان كان واخيرا واخيرا هم استطاعوا على
مدار السنوات تجريد الشعب الفلسطيني من
انسانيته تجريد كل فلسطيني من انسانيته
والعالم تابع
البيانات والتصريحات لقاده اسرائيل على
اعلى مستوى سياسي وعسكري بما فيها وصف
وزير الدفاع للشعب الفلسطيني انهم حيوانات
بشريه وما قالوا نتنياهو وما قالوا اخرون
هذا ه جمع كل هذه العوامل تخرج بان
بالنسبه لاسرائيل السلام يعني اشياء مشوهه
جدا ولهذا متطلبات السلام واضحه اولا
السلام ليس حصول طرف واحد على الامن مش
هذا هو السلام ليس هذا هو السلام بل
السلام هو نتاج نتاج مخرج من حصول الجميع
كل الاطراف على الامن على الاستقرار على
الازدهار على الاحترام على تحقيق الحقوق
حقوق ولهذا يبدا السلام يبدا السلام عندما
ينتهي الاحتلال يبدا السلام عندما ينتهي
الاستعمار والحصار ونظام الفصل العنصري
يبدا السلام عندما توقف اسرائيل كل
ممارساتها غير القانونيه جرائم الحرب بما
فيها اعتقال اطفالنا بما فيها التنكيل
بشعبنا في كل مكان بما فيها سرقه اراضينا
وتدمير بيوتنا السلام يبدا بالاعتراف بحق
الشعب الفلسطيني في تغرير مصير وحقنا في
العوده الى بيوتنا يبدا السلام عندما
تنتهي كل هذه الممارسات والخرق للقانون
الدولي ويبدا السلام عندما نطبق بشكل
متساوي ومتكافئ وكامل للقانون الدولي
والقرارات الدوليه والشرعيه الدوليه هناك
نتحدث عن السلام الوقت الان يتطلب منا ان
نعيد وان نستعيد المعنى السامي والحقيقي
للسلام وان نقدم كما يجب ان تقدم لشعوبنا
وكل شعوب العالم السلام صعب السلام يتطلب
العداله السلام يتطلب اراده سياسيه حقيقيه
ولكنه ممكن
ممكن